and we're back ladies and gentlemen
welcome to another episode of hey [ __ ]
hello so happy I'm so happy to have
everyone back how are we doing everybody
how do we not you guys I'm talking to
them well I'm doing good I hope you guys
are too and I hope everyone else except
Gio is doing great today too
oh well thank you I'm fantastic I'm
traumatized so on today's episode we we
have myself Gio you have me over here hi
Gina
Bo's and Jessica today we're gonna we're
gonna turn it down a little bit to
really turn it up because turned down
will we get emotional yes yeah we're
gonna turn it up a bit and this is
something that I've been reading in the
comments thank you all everyone that's
been leaving comments and stuff and
hitting us in the dm's we're getting all
of those we love you but the thing I
keep seeing over and over and over again
is a bunch of girls and some locate
dudes I I see you too what you guys are
talking about like oh my god I've never
had a group of girlfriends um it's so
hard for me to make girlfriends and now
you guys feel like you guys are my
girlfriends and I'm like wait why is
this a thing like why is it so hard to
make girlfriends and that's something
that I want to shed some light on today
and that's what I mean by we're gonna
we're gonna turn it down horrible first
of all everyone in the comments we're
your girlfriends now yeah you can't have
anymore
yeah can't have anymore okay captain
girls were your girlfriends guys we're
we're your wing women women yeah yes but
why is it so hard for girls to like why
is that it why is that like a thing
we're like girls can the girls are so
catty yes they can't get along with each
other from personal experience I've been
through this before because my 20s like
my early 20s was really hard to find a
girlfriend like a close group of friends
because you're not in your early
twenties 47 because I feel like girls
when they're younger in that age they're
still like somewhat in competition
because they're still trying to learn
about themselves and trying to be the
better
I want the dudes and they really care
about male attention for instance there
was this girl that I knew that was
hanging out with for a little bit and I
thought we were cool I got we were
friends like hanging out her house I met
her parents right we were friends for a
few months and then she was a little bit
heavier set she's you know a little bit
shorter than me and this was during when
I already had started modeling in my
early like teen years right and I
remember I was hanging out her house and
she was getting ready I was like oh
what's up I was like in my sweats and
she goes oh you know I met these guys
online and like I want to hang out with
them and I have a crush on him and he's
bringing his friends and stuff and me
being at her house I was like oh I would
come you know like I don't want to go
home can I come and then she straight up
just said I don't really want you to
come because I feel like they'll pay
more attention to you mm-hmm
and I was just like ouch that's weird
like you're my friend you know and I was
like if you want I can wipe off my
makeup and tie up my hair or something
she's like yeah that'd be cool and then
she like we were just going to eat
during the daytime I think we went to
like a fast food restaurant just went
out to the dudes house to like hang out
right it was daytime is she dressed up
like she was in a nightclub she's like a
skin-tight dress on and heels on right
and shoot like at one point we were
walking down the sidewalk and she was
walking in front of us but I guess like
she was like okay the guys are behind me
I gotta walk like I have an ass so she
walked like like a duck she was like a
cracked-out Peg Bundy
old reference yeah I didn't make it I
didn't make it so she was walking like
this in her heels like really trying to
make her a stick out and the guys just
looked at me like hey she okay
yeah his way psycho yeah and then I was
like I don't know and then later on I
found out that she was telling people
cuz she was talking to these guys but
like they ended up liking me more
because I was not weird yeah I need the
makeup okay and then they were like you
know she tells us terrible things about
you like how you like got pregnant or
you [ __ ] yourself with the remote
control and you're a [ __ ] and I was oh
dude like I was so heartbroken like
about you were mindful they're all lies
yeah we need to clear we know the story
back here but you need to tell them yeah
those are lies
and then so later on I developed a
friendship with another girl she was
older I was 18 she was 25 she's one who
got me into gogo dancing and this is
like you know short shortly after I
ditched that other girl the really
shitty one and I was talking to her and
my girl's been through [ __ ] like she's
been through life and you know lived she
was a model too she knew about other
females and stuff and she was like you
you do know why that happened right and
then I was like why she goes this might
sound really shitty but if you hang out
with girls that are less attractive than
you they might grow resentful and they
do [ __ ] like that to you and then I
didn't want to really believe it I'm
like well no there's some good people
out there but then I've seen it happened
before when guys come around and the
girl wants the most attention that she
starts putting you down
oh she's nothing I'm like well [ __ ]
[ __ ] people are these yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude so like that happens and I was like
dude that's really shitty and that's
exactly what happens you're the first
girl damn I didn't have that problem
because I know what I looked like you
know I think part of the reason why and
like so many people have said like oh I
wish I had girlfriends like that I think
part of the reason why we all worked out
is because we all met at the right time
yes like we're old enough we're much
more mature and I think that and like I
feel comfortable saying this all of us
[ __ ] are like a little damaged like
all of us in here and like the rest of
our group I've never heard that
we're we're a little damaged oh come on
Gio we have some problems in life that
you know that's who we are
Gio live the perfect life cool hot mom
businesswoman sqk looks amazing
literally want her to step on me not
even the front part of the foot just the
heat I got two bows I just wanted to run
me over with your Tesla [ __ ] it okay
fine no I was a joke that turned really
wrong like I didn't want we love you no
thank you but no so we're all damaged I
do a little damage and if if we had all
met you know at 13:15 or if we had been
buddies on Twitter I think all of us
would have pushed each other away like
in some way shape or form like it's just
a man Gio push each other away in the
beginning I think we would have been
best friends though probably didn't push
each other away no I think I think um I
don't know like I get I understand her I
feel like so I think we would have I
don't know I feel like we would all be
friends yeah because we're just very
okay so for me I don't know if you're
done with your thought but at least for
me I've just noticed in my all of my
circle of friends like I've never had
that where like I had I've had hot
girlfriends but I've never was like oh
my god to pay more attention to her I'm
just like hell yeah I'm kicking it with
the hot girls yeah me too no like I was
just happy to be in that circle but they
grow resentful after a while because we
would have girls like that are great
like dude like I grew up with models and
Gogan answers right and there's always
like the one like that wasn't in that
scene she was just an you know a regular
girl I hung out with this and she would
get kind of upset like there are times
when she was like no one's [ __ ]
talking to me you know it's just like
alright I mean you're only hanging out
with this you know those are dudes talk
to you like that's us why don't you just
enjoying your time with us so they
sometimes they do grow resentful yeah I
think the only issues that I've ever had
was that I'm too outspoken and I say
things and and the receiving party tends
to be really sensitive and receiving it
so that's always kind of been my issue
because I'll just say [ __ ] and and like
like I'll be like oh you have a booger
yeah you know and they would be like why
would you say that why wouldn't you tell
me like I'm like what the [ __ ] I thought
I did you a favor if you told me that so
that don't look stupid I'm like that's
kind of cool I actually did notice about
that
about that I didn't notice that about
God about you hello um and then that's
what I liked about you though because
like you and I poke fun of each other
all the time
you know like and it worked out for me
like it made me happy like oh cool I
have someone that I can talk about
comfortably or talk about dumb [ __ ]
comfortably just like Jill your tits
look saggy today and you like your all
should be able to roast each other yeah
you should I like I've been through
where I met this one girl who I thought
was cool and we played a very harmless
joke I like prank on her and she was
pissed and was never my friend again I
literally bought her a bellybutton ring
that she didn't like oh he had a
mustache and she's like yeah this is a
[ __ ] joke why would you buy this for
me like it like people like that
sometimes they don't click well with you
and I've met people like that oh yeah I
get what you're talking about you know
what's interesting to me is like you
know kind of coming into this
conversation I felt like we all were on
the very same page of like okay we
didn't always get along with some women
but I'm starting to feel like our
reasons why are all very very different
because I hadn't experienced what you
experienced I mean like what what was
your experience for you um that I I
don't know it just it was weird cuz like
I was always like very open and I was
like here's my [ __ ] here you go like
a friend and I'll have your back
regardless but then somehow I would get
weeded out like I don't even understand
how that would happen interesting and
I'm thinking it's because I was just too
open mind or like to like open to say
things or maybe I just was too crass or
I don't know what it was where it was
like okay don't invite don't invite her
like maybe I was too weird huh you know
mines I'll try to condense it but like
this is gonna sound like very like brash
but I also feel like this is a space
where I can be open and honest and even
where the audience will accept me and I
think it's important to share
experiences that are like that run
pretty deep because maybe it'll help you
understand someone else that you know
but like in my life like it sounds like
really kind of dramatic but I was very
sexist because I had a lot of women in
my life that failed me from like family
to mentors to friends I've been in LA
for three years and there's not a single
person with the exception of my one best
friend that I still talked to that's a
woman I mean I worked at Hooters so like
I met a lot of like girls that were like
I don't know just
a lot of not like the most top-tier
cream-of-the-crop girls and I went
through some really shitty experiences
from a kid like all the way up into an
adult and so I have this very sexist
image in my head that this this is what
women are you know I was like they do
this they do this what is that what does
that mean what is this
I had a I'm just bad experiences from A
to Z with women and in it like this is
like gonna sound so wack and some of you
guys have met her when I moved to LA the
first woman that changed my opinion of
that was Mari Mari takahashi that I
worked with that Smosh atomic yeah
atomic Mari she is a very like poised
strong powerful woman and in my 25 years
I had never seen that before I had never
seen a like hard-working strong woman
like that because I was dealing with
dramatic gossipy disrespectful like just
just the worst types of women and I have
never seen anyone like her before and so
that was my first step into thinking
wait a minute not every woman is what I
saw in small-town Virginia and I think
there's a lot of people that that is
what they see every day through that's a
good point that is that is really what
they see and that goes for races that
goes for sexes that goes for how some
women feel about men you know etc and
you could not you know no matter all the
stuff I'm seeing about feminism and
everything online if I was still in
Virginia and I had never met some of the
women that I had met I would be like
y'all are [ __ ] crazy women but things
not but it took me coming out here and
meeting women like her meeting women
like you guys that show me like wait a
minute there are some boss ass [ __ ]
and like you know you you gotta like
move past that but you have to see it to
believe it sometimes oh damn yeah and
that's and so I think sometimes I pushed
away or looked down on some women
because that was my experience and I
feel comfortable sharing that with you
guys yeah that's awesome
yeah that's a good that's some good
insight dude and I'm sure a lot of
people can relate to that for sure Jesse
had a group of friends back in Texas a
bunch of girlfriends yeah what was that
like no I never really had a large group
of room friends I'm the same as you guys
I've always had like one or two really
close and then sometimes they mix and
they move like I've so I probably have
like say 10 girls that I know right but
none of them are all friends with each
other so like I'm one of the three in
this area I'm one of the two more here
like they're all like different girls so
like some are from college summer from
Hooters some are from this summer from
that having an entire group of girls
like this is definitely a whole new
dynamic I don't think I've ever had the
experience with the competing for men
thing if other girls pushed me out
because of that I wasn't aware of it but
I've had a lot more of like what Geo and
Moses saying like I don't respect a lot
of women that I've seen until like I got
here that same thing and then also I'm
I'm so I am crass to I think me and geo
are kind of the same like because I'll
just be like [ __ ] you geo but then like
I'm like oh she misses me she knows that
I'm just playing around like I can say
whatever I want pretty much I mean not
to be like outrageously disrespectful
but she's pretty [ __ ] up I can say
whatever I want and then like she'll be
able to read when I'm actually [ __ ] up
in pissed or when I'm just playing
around so like I think for a lot of
girls they can't do that yeah yeah so I
pushed a lot of people away because I'm
I'm just like being super myself and
it's like too much for women to
understand or something like it's like
this chick I don't get it because even
in high school um I had more guy friends
and girlfriends and I know there's like
that [ __ ] saying yeah everyone your
face but it wasn't like that like I
never felt like guys were trying to get
at me I always felt like I was a dude
like if I show you pictures yeah high
school like I mean when I was in high
school like I wasn't attractive it's a
tomboy thing same way so I was one of
the dudes I'm like yeah let's [ __ ] go
get stoned or yeah let's go [ __ ]
let's pretend like I know how to
skateboard like that it wasn't ever like
kgo I was best friends with high school
geo like I was a tomboy like what is it
Lance Anderson playing Counter Strike
with all the boys field from like middle
school up till high school so I had a
lot more guy friends too and then girls
kind of saw that as oh she's a ho she
just hangs out with a bunch of guys and
I was like dude I just like friends you
know I think what's also kind of
interesting I was talking to my brothers
before I think that everyone kind of has
their own like moral compass and I think
some people's compass points north west
Souths it doesn't matter where it points
but you tend to gravitate towards people
that are pointed in the same direct
ratio yeah and I think that you know why
our group kind of grew so slowly it was
because like you know you guys started
off with the base of all the JK news
girls and slowly other girls started to
assimilate you know and some people pass
by and it's like oh they didn't quite
you know match where we were pointed but
like we real I think all of us are
really going like in a similar direction
and that's why we gravitate towards each
other like when I meet a girl that's
like kind of the same compasses me my
receptors like beep yeah yeah yeah like
in it's very quickly I got that with
TIFF when I met her I met TIFF first and
like we just connected like it was wild
and like I feel the same way about all
of you guys too yeah I don't know I
don't know what it is um like now that
I'm older I do get to I agree with what
you just said 100% where it's now I like
to stick around people that have the
same type of goals or attitude and when
it comes to life like it's not like a
male-female thing but I guess I'm just
trying to think back to when I was in
high school and I was like damn like why
do I feel so [ __ ] lonely like I see
like at least TV I don't even know if
this is a reality for other girls um but
at least I would see you on TV and [ __ ]
like oh my god they have all their
girlfriends and they're going to over to
each other's houses all the time like
when can I have that so I guess I'm just
trying to get to that point like how do
we help someone that was in my shoes hmm
when I was younger there yeah I was a
[ __ ] loser to like have friends and
to like trust those guys don't have that
problem like it comes with age too like
a lot of us we're just now finding this
group right right the first time for me
too I only had like one best friend from
high school that I'm still friends with
and then I added another group another
girl like maybe like only 2 years ago so
this is new to me like I'll see on
Instagram where girls have like
bachelorette parties and bridesmaids and
there's like 20 oh what oh I don't know
any story for that so I had just moved
out of my house is the first time I ever
moved out I found a room like on
roommates thumb or something like that
so I found a house with three other
girls and I had just moved in I just
lived it for maybe about a month and one
of the girls was like hey or maybe like
three months but the girl was like hey
so we're gonna get married soon and I
wanted to know if he wanted to be one of
my
and I was like what she's cool she was
really cool she was a sweet girl but I
was like are you sure like you don't
even know me that's a commitment yeah I
mean I didn't have to do much but just
wear a dress and then I get free food
and I'm part of a wedding like that's
kind of cool like I wanted to be part of
some of the wedding but I was like this
is kind of weird like as it normally
happened like that but I think what's
happening is a lot of people have to put
up this front mmm I have a lot of
friends a cool life that I have like I
have a cool car but instead of just
being like I don't have any [ __ ]
friends like yeah this is us - we don't
need Brides me yeah awesome
yeah I mean we had friends we just
didn't want you guys in the wedding game
yeah y'all had a really chill wedding be
like I'll see you something I'm like
dude do all 20 of you guys really know
each other that well to be in a wedding
together but I really think it does come
with age like Bosa
like we now are business focused family
folks and all that and we all have that
in common that's why we get along so
well so a lot of people in their 20s are
still trying to find that because it's a
lot of people are sometimes in their 20s
they're still partying or they're still
yeah living at home and some are working
on their business and stuff like that
I've met so many people in different
walks of life like age let's talk about
one of our sponsors care of makes you
know care of a custom-made little
vitamin packets where you take a quiz
online and they give you custom-made
vitamin packets so your name has your
name on it and cute little quotes on it
so all you have to do is go on their
website it's carob calm you take a
little quiz and what you want to take
care of like your hair your gut your
digestion your skin whatever yeah and
they put together a cute little packet
for you so they customize the formula to
you and everything you want to take care
of
yeah and it's cool because they even
asked you would you rather take one
big-ass pill or 12 pills at once and
they put them in these cute little
compartments about every day and take
your vitamins and it gets delivered to
your house and yeah it's super
convenient they also have protein powder
if you didn't know that
I already resolved opals the chocolate
protein problem they also have these
little packs of like b12 vitamins and
caffeine called extra batteries yeah so
cute I love them the other thing that I
feel like I noticed was it they're very
high quality supplements like they
really are like the extra batter
it's like the smoothest energy I've ever
helped they've like felt it's better
than like waiting yeah yeah it's orange
flavor it's so great I love those so
much but it made me realize like how
high-quality the product was yeah and I
think the other really cool thing is
like when you're worried about your hair
your sleep schedule your mental energy
to take a pill that's custom tailored to
you each day it just makes you feel good
you feel ready to like kick ass for the
day because you know you're taking care
of yourself getting into a healthy
routine and doing the best thing for you
personally yeah
so for this wait what is it for 25% off
your first care 25% off your first care
of order goats you take care of calm and
enter BT CH to get your vitamins and
your dissol bowls and your proteins
that's 25% off your first care of order
go to take care of calm and enter B T
ch3 5% off that's amazing the funniest
[ __ ] too is like now that I think about
that like if we met a girl right now
that just loved to party like she wants
to go out every weekend we be like oh no
more [ __ ] but all of us we have it in
us to oh let's dress up and go to Vegas
tonight yeah and then two months later
yeah let's go clubbing and you know like
we can have fun but we're on the same
page about it you know yeah and I feel
like all of us kind of had to drag
ourselves out of the house at night but
then at the end of the night we had a
[ __ ] blast yeah yep yep you guys saw
on Geo story no but I'm just saying like
but why don't guys go through the [ __ ]
do you know what I mean I don't know
like really wondered so when I had so
when I was in my 20s I'm still trying to
figure myself out I had a boyfriend he
had a bunch of friends and then I kind
of became part of the friends circle
through him once we broke up I still
kept those friends but I'm like [ __ ] why
couldn't I do this with girls I think
that I think that women and particularly
us I think a lot of us are very deep
thinkers and for guys it's very surface
level like you lobby
yeah just he want to [ __ ] chill cool
let's chill it's whatever you know my
boyfriend he doesn't really have a lot
of the same values as his friends but
they're all great friends I think for us
we're thinking really hard like does she
like this does she want to do this or do
I really get a
we think about it a lot but like in turn
wheat but then there are some girls that
don't some girls that just like it's not
very important to them they're not
thinking on a deep level they're
thinking on a surface level and like
that's okay like I wish I had that and I
think that that's why so many of us that
feel lonely it's because we're deep
thinkers and very emotional people yeah
and I think the nice way to put it yeah
I think that pieces of [ __ ] one of the
things that you know like I was like
like Gina was saying like yeah we're
older now and I'm trying to like probe
my brain like well what's so different
about us now they were older and I think
one of the things I learned is that when
I meet somebody that has the same values
as me instead of being afraid of like
will she like me or not I'm like I'm
going in like I'm gonna show this girl
that I'm a ride-or-die I'm an idiot I
didn't show someone though you i I think
you should when we were younger I think
everyone was a little shy to connect and
reach out you know and like you're
afraid to getting rejected by these
other girls and I think that that fear
went away from me as I got older because
my receptors got a little stronger and I
knew that I would vibe with this girl so
all I have to do is extend my hand and I
think that when you're younger I wish
that I had extended my hand to a few
more people and not just extended it but
nourish that relationship and sometimes
you're so afraid of rejection we don't
do that and you know it's it's not
really that hard you're the only thing
you're fighting is yourself
yeah I think actually that really makes
little sense how guys are more like
they're not as I'm not saying you're
dumb but they don't go in I said yeah I
think you're saying they're dumb but
they don't really go into it like girls
I know a group of girls that kind of cut
in one girl off because well she didn't
want to come out with us tonight so
obviously she does want to hang out with
us and I feel like when it comes to guys
like George is tired or whatever it's
just go pound some beers and that's it
you know I think it's like that to you
they don't go through that emotional
they don't talk about everything yeah
like bows do you think I'm a little bit
overwhelming you know you would tell me
things and all that guys talk about [ __ ]
like that now I don't really have a
reason to hurt each other's feelings in
case one of them is more sensitive than
the other you know I'm really fun an
example of this is like the okay the guy
I'm dating now we like there will be
times where he'll do something and I'm
like well he must have thought this and
done this and done this and I'm
just now starting to realize as a person
that didn't grow up with a father figure
I do I don't have a good receptor of
guy's brains and I'm just now figuring
out that guys don't [ __ ] care no like
they do not [ __ ] you know like they are
not thinking whenever you're thinking
about say you're thinking is a hundred
percent the guy's only thinking 25
percent of that it's not because he's
stupid or anything it's just because
he's paying they hit guys pay attention
to things not a mower in the moment yeah
you know and like it's they're not
thinking like on this deep level that we
do that to an extent almost holds us
back so it's a handicap for sure yeah
yeah I mean I guess I guess I I will
agree with that I know guys do don't get
really deep in thinking about stuff and
you're right like these are a lot of
arguments that we had in the past with
my husband where I'm like dude it's so
obvious like why don't you see it and
right in front of you like I'm being
this way uh-huh and like it they could
I'm like it's so [ __ ] obvious and
he's like I'm just a dude I don't get it
like that is just not how yeah like even
something as small is like I don't know
like if he didn't pick something off the
floor and he walks right by it and I'm
like hello like you're being so
inconsiderate like it's right there he's
like dude I have dude eyes like I didn't
even have you know I think one example
that I have with myself was um I didn't
think I was part of you guys is group
for a long time No yeah like Japan and
Suffolk cuz I actually sometimes I still
do sometimes just a little bit but not
as much as before
I sit down like man I wish I was you
know like to the point more like Comfort
work I just come over to Gio's house
whenever I wants you and really needs ya
like because Tiffany's always over there
with the beat a little preppy seat right
like that's so fun yeah and then for me
I'm just like oh man I wish I was like
okay come over anytime I also like I'm
balling cuz that's the over thinking I'm
like what if she's busy what if she's
breastfeeding what if she Sue's I mean
for my god I never thought you in a
million what ever think that you're so
[ __ ] open oh yeah but I this is why
we can't have Thai girl group I think
you're [ __ ] my yeah and then so like
it's like or you guys will have like oh
we're having a potluck and I'm sitting
there like man I wish I was there but
then I do know that there were times
when I traveled so much that you guys
just assumed that I wasn't available and
also we're bad at inviting people too
but are you coming over tonight to the
fight I can't I got a good idea
okay but yeah like light and that's the
over thinking like am i part of the JK
girls group like do they actually like
me like do they want to invite me and
stuff like that so slowly easy yeah so
slowly I started infiltrating right like
Tiffany and I would go to events Jessica
and I would go shopping you know and
then you know it's funny because at that
time I felt like you were way more JK
than I was you know because like you're
way more in the group before I was
really yeah like you guys were like you
guys were like solid in because you were
in the JK core staff and I was just
still a guest you know I mean so you are
there hydro like in a video y'all crazy
I look from episode 1 I was like this is
my house now Jess take that feature now
I've said this feels so we had this is
what started the whole podcast was we
had this this group chat called host
pace that we would always talk about and
one time Bo's heard about this chat and
she was like can I get in on that what
the [ __ ] do you was like
we have a meeting of the council but you
know what I was the one that was like
put bows in yeah I've already [ __ ]
been damn in this [ __ ] about my feet I
want bows in the chat so I was like geo
if I can put her in its scary dude cuz
we all work in entertainment and some we
just screenshot our shouldn't post it
you know
but if oh my god I don't even think like
that let me clear it up so I didn't
think that you would screen such
screenshot some [ __ ] like that's that's
wild that you thought that that's
[ __ ] smart I should remember that
I just thought that you were gonna [ __ ]
up the whole group that's gonna be like
a waste of time with us yeah I mean
you're on the show right okay yeah no
you're all you're small you fit anywhere
we put you all right in my black one I
would not have called you fuzz looking
for the black one okay wait I have a
question because I'm like I'm still like
probably my brain or like why do we fit
together like why do I okay question
like what what do you guys think is
something that we all have in common
with each other or like you know what I
mean sarcasm the fact that we're not so
open about everything yeah yeah I mean
sure women who can show each other our
titties well beause you're still working
on want to show my brother it's okay
just because we're so open and we're so
real with each other like everyone's
always complaining about only people are
so fake but it's like no like I love how
open we are like I remember I hit up Gio
I can end up Gio for anything like yo
Gio I want to go to a plastic surgeon
who did your titties and she'll just
[ __ ] like yo I'll FaceTime we're like
I'll show you my titties real quick or
stuff like that or I can even
straight-up ask you how much did you get
for this brand deal so I know what to
ask for and she'll tell me straight up
and those are like I want to be around
the nothing that I have to hide I want
to be real with them and I want them to
be back real back with me yeah I'd like
that's that's literally it and I think
part of what it is is that like when I
talk to you guys never once have I
questioned if what you said is what you
meant yeah like
everywhere that comes out of your mouth
I know that that's exactly what you mean
and like a lot of times people
especially in LA they have ulterior
motives I was dealing with like people
that every single word was not what they
[ __ ] met knew every single word and
like it hurt me like everyday you know
like why can't like why can't you be an
honest person it doesn't make sense to
me but there's so many people that are
like that and so like the minute they're
like I just felt like you guys were
being honest like with your words with
your emotions and everything so I was
like okay these these people were real
like and I love that I get that from you
I get that I get that vibe from you that
you've been like ticked over quite a bit
there's times like you're super [ __ ]
open and I trust everything that you say
but there's times to where we'll bring
something up or I'll bring something up
and I feel like a little bit resistance
from you or I'm like oh she's not
comfortable with this I mean I'm in a
way I don't know specifically off the
top of my head what it is but you sound
a little reserved sometimes I'm like oh
she's been [ __ ] around with and the
best thing is even if you're
uncomfortable we don't push it you know
like yeah things before and we just
don't push it okay that's cool then
we'll talk about you know to other
people we don't make you feel left out -
that's true they were just chasing me
around showing me their breasts both
show us your boobs now it's like I'll
show you guys after the episode and they
were like okay the other thing I like
about this group is that we really do
encourage each other to be our best and
then we also help each other out a lot
like I think one thing that really stood
out to me not just in this group but
with JK was when Joe had us all coming
for a meeting to meet with his
accountant and then Joe's like I got
these books for you guys because I want
you guys to succeed he got us a rich
dead quartet and he's like I'm here to
teach you guys like my accounts here to
teach you about everything I was like
wow this dude actually cares about it
wants us to succeed and that's the same
thing with like like the whole group of
girls like if I'm going through
something TIFF will help me out if Gio
like I actually had a naked spa day with
Gio and TIFF wait like years ago and I'm
like I want to start my youtube channel
can you help me she was like yeah dude
let's [ __ ] do it
and then like me and TIFF and Jill once
his spa she busted out her her laptop
she's like okay what topics do you want
to talk about what do you how do you
want to do like people like we really do
help each other Jessica's like I want to
update my wardrobe let's go shopping
like luck yeah let's go you know and
like I like that everyone wants to help
each other and
help each other succeed instead of just
like helping themselves also can we do a
shopping trips inner beauty you [ __ ]
talk about this all the time I just my
packing yes I just got it in but give it
to them Jess so this one's function of
beauty it's um it's a haircare brand
they have shampoo conditioner stuff like
that are you smelling Mike is my hair
several days old with dry shampoo in it
so don't judge it I live that life too I
live that life - smells good so anyways
a function of beauty is addresses all
hair care needs not just one and so with
function and beauty you can choose up to
five hair goals to add to your
formulation so what they do is you take
a little quiz and then you talk about
what's going on with your hair is it
bleached is it dries and brittle is it
breaking is it curly find the Curly's
that you like what's your texture like
what do you want to happen with your
hair like do you have blonde hair and
you wanted to get rid of brassiness so
they know ok well we'll give you the
purple shampoo or like it so you just
customized exactly the way you want it
yep and they're current yeah and the
color I got the peach one dude I'm such
a [ __ ] for like customized [ __ ] like
you choose the color they say and even
on the bottle it says function of Gina
yeah like it's just different
and I said Gio oh my god mine said bows
I actually got mine with no fragrance in
it because I've been having some skin
issues so I didn't want any fragrance in
mine that's amazing conditioner yeah
there's also no sulfates parabens
phthalates mineral oils or harmful
ingredients and it's vegan and cruelty
free y'all hear that hmm yeah I love
this stuff I absolutely love it I will
buy it again even though I got it for
free the first time I'm gonna put this
code in and I'm gonna buy it when I run
out and that code is for 20% off go to a
function of beauty calm slash b tch and
take their hair profile quiz and you'll
get 20% off if you go to function of
beauty calm slash b tch and the first
time actually how did Tiffany gave it to
me for my birthday like a couple years
ago and all those trends man yeah and
then I ran out and I've been wanting
again so thanks for sponsoring yeah
we'll definitely keep using that product
for sure it keeps your hair nice and
soft for the puling 's yeah good job
how one thing one thing I do like about
my relationship with geo which i think
is oh my god let's talk about yeah
it's hard to find in a lot of women is
that we like we used to fight like not
fight but like we didn't like each other
right so yeah we didn't get along in the
beginning it was like a year and a half
almost two years where we didn't get
along and then we finally sat down and
we got to a like a just a good place
with each other we're like okay we'll
just be chill like we initiated that me
oh oh [ __ ] not getting along for the
longest time and like I'm in the core
for right with the job rgo and then
there's Jess but then I'm like I'm never
gonna [ __ ] fit in the [ __ ] if I don't
get it right with you so we sat down and
all of that but then now all of this
time goes by and like if I'm [ __ ] up
gyeo will call me and be like hey you're
[ __ ] up like this is what you need to
do better and I'm like willing I don't
say it that [ __ ] up no no no now I'm
like you know just speaking quickly but
she'll be like I think this is how like
you should think about going about doing
this I think you could be better at
doing that and like I'm willing to be
vulnerable enough to let her tell me
that I [ __ ] up my actions are not good
like it's a friendship it's like a real
[ __ ] up because I'm just like I will
let her check me because I know that she
has my best interest at heart and like I
think with a lot of girls if you're not
willing to be vulnerable and like let
them check you when they feel [ __ ] up
like you did something I kind of don't
like the way it sounded or what you did
but then a lot of girls will not be
vulnerable enough yeah okay maybe I did
[ __ ] up and like she actually cares
enough like that's why she's telling me
not because she wants me to feel bad but
because she wants to be my friend and
she wants things to like be fixed so we
can continue to be free once the best
for you is your communication with her
bleeds over into almost every
relationship in your life yeah
yeah and then you know depending like
you had the humility to be able to take
that advice other girls might get angry
be like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about that breaks friendship yeah so you
have to have that vulnerability to
accept criticism from your friends who
really want the best and it's harder to
take criticism from women than it is
from men and I don't
know why but that's something like that
we I think all women have to sit down
and be like why is it so hard for me to
take criticism like from a woman I think
it all boils personally I think it all
boils down to that's just human nature
and women we were you know like like an
animalistic nature we have to be the
best and strongest to protect our
children protect our bloodline whatever
you know so I think that's a like that's
like a human I just lost my train of
thought I think that's a human nature
like in a primitive standpoint it's
almost like like how sometimes women we
had to fight each other for the hottest
man the alpha man like on a very like
primitive level we are used to fighting
each other we weren't always allies
because I thought we were nurturers what
the [ __ ] we are nurturers who our own
babies yeah so we find our man we hunt
him down and we [ __ ] yeah our babies
do you ever see I mean like we grew up
in villages and [ __ ] we're like social
creatures we're not like isolated
creatures that's that's and then if
you're if you're in a village and you're
not able to give babies whatever they
cast like they cast you out or [ __ ] like
that like I did and I'm back then but I
mean also scientifically what Jaden was
saying before where she she had some bad
experiences with shady women and so did
I so psychologically it's a little
engrained with us it when five a woman
says some [ __ ] to you and then at
ten it happens again and so at 20 after
a few times being told some [ __ ]
we're like is she [ __ ] with me you
know yeah there are also some women that
will give you constructive criticism but
they really just want to hurt you they
want to tell you what's wrong with you
yeah and like that call themselves
brutally honest but they're more anxious
but they're more interested in the
brutal part than the honesty part like
and you know what there's there's girls
that will give you
this criticism but it's like are you
trying to help me are you trying to hurt
me and it matters to delivery and I
think what Gio really excels at is Gio
like you know if you say something that
she and she maybe knows what the
probably the right path or correct
answer is she will say help me
understand you know like your point of
view on this she's gonna listen to you
first oh damn this is Gio show with the
girl just jackin off right now
but I mean like that's that's definitely
something you an excel in and you know
when you're detecting every girl needs
that one friend that's gonna tell you
how it is every girl needs to because
that's the girl that's gonna help you
grow but you can figure out is this a
friend or a foe based off of the way she
tells it to you
is it a quick sting because you're
beating yourself up because of what you
did or is it a pain that lasts for a few
days where you feel guilty if it's a
pain that lasts for a few days then that
person was not trying to help you they
were probably trying to hurt you yeah
because if they speak to tell you it
correctly you feel the pain of a [ __ ] I
did that but then they're helping you
work out the solution and now you feel
better because you're not gonna make
that mistake again and [ __ ] those
[ __ ] trying to hurt you okay yeah
forget them I think what I've just
noticed um just being older coz I am the
oldest person in this group what am i 35
41 27 Wow
brendan pho is here no yeah and I've
just noticed that people are just
obviously saralyn in security right like
we've learned that now at our at our
ripe age that whatever they're telling
you it's really just because that's just
how they feel about themselves but I
just realized that a lot of people are
just out to kind of they feel like I
feel like the competition still kind of
there like even if it's even if it's
just male like they're still competing
for that slot or for that piece of the
pie where I'm just like what the [ __ ]
are you competing about like you're your
own person and you have really dope
things to bring to the table like I can
learn from that like why wouldn't I want
to accept you in this group if I feel
that you're being genuine about your
[ __ ] like regardless of how you're
packaging it or whatever but if I feel
you're being dope like why wouldn't I
want to share and like grow with you
like I just think that's just weird
mm-hmm I don't know yeah I think it's
like really undervalued that you know
every every lick relationship you have a
somebody there's always something you
can learn from that person like what is
the thing that you absolutely like the
most about them and it's like how can I
like adopt a similar habit and grow
myself like the people around you should
make you grow stronger you know like
that and I I definitely like feel this
like in this group like Jeana always has
like a very consistent grind like you're
you're consistent with the work and
everything you do like Geo was like I
wanna do something and then she just
does it
just happens and then Jess so I am I
think this I think i'ma burn for a
couple I think the thing that's probably
the most inspiring about dress is that
she was so afraid to break out of her
shell and then you know what she woke up
one day and said [ __ ] it I'm doing this
and like that's [ __ ] dope like it's
something that you've been afraid of
doing for the past couple of years and
then you finally said you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] and like that there's there's
always something cool that you can
recognize your friends and you know what
if you're not seeing something positive
that you feel like you can learn from
[ __ ] them
we gotta go there's actually just did
something recently that kind of blew me
away actually and and I realized this is
what I admire about Jess it's that one
thing actually happened I was late for
this because obviously a wicked before
p.m. but the group chat was going off
and then just straight up just messaged
us and I know where she goes guys I
figure out what was bothering me and she
was so clear and concise about it
because a lot of people struggle with
figuring out what is wrong with them
what they need help on what they need to
fix her you know do different and then
just just straight up when I figured out
what's wrong with me this is what's
bothering me I see it here now I found
it here and I want to change this and
I'm gonna do this and she opened it up
to us and let us in and talk to her and
that's really like it's it's very
inspiring for me because people do not
like to be vulnerable like that right
yeah but the fact that you were age yeah
the fact that you were able to identify
it so well was incredible and then you
actually put it out there I was like
[ __ ] I'm going through a lot like this
is the summer of like me [ __ ]
fighting the last piece of myself that I
hate learning how to like forgive myself
and everyone else and like letting go of
like because I'm such an Iowa stick
person now forever I've just been like
life sucks we're all gonna die but now
I'm like I said that like three weeks
it's slow it's a slow burn but yeah I'm
just trying to figure all of that out
and it feels good I think to have other
females that I can share the experience
with because I feel like that was
another part of like something that was
wrong with me is like why can't I get
close to like a lot of people at once
it's always like oh I can only latch on
to one person and that's it you know
like now I know I can latch on to like
six or seven people all at once and it's
actually feels way healthier there's
like way much more energy there's
different like I'm bouncing off of more
than one person so I'm able to grow a
lot faster with all these different
energies and I really enjoy it and
that's what happens when you have a good
group of girlfriends that you can trust
and talk to like I've seen you change
like crazy and I see like the effort see
when it's [ __ ] awesome you know
because I remember for awhile I was like
I don't know how to connect to this girl
I really want to be her friend and then
you invited me out to go shopping I was
like oh [ __ ] yeah we're friends you know
like and that's what I like that's why I
love this group so much because everyone
gets along because we want to help each
other and we do really want you at us
for each other yeah mm-hmm yeah I do
agree with that um yeah yeah with Jess
and I mean she's still getting
finger-banged over there huh that's one
of the things that I found really dope
about her and I've kind of kicked myself
in the ass a little bit where I'm like
man why was she such a [ __ ] in the
beginning look but I know what it is
because I'm so protective of the ones
that I love and stuff that I just don't
want anything to harm any one of them
that I'm just like like I don't know if
this [ __ ] is temporary or not so right
yeah and she's coming in with this like
bad [ __ ] vibe and stuff I'm just like
I don't know I don't know her I don't
like her she's [ __ ] up the group so
I'm like alright let's [ __ ] me
protect you guys no but it was tight
when she called me I'm like let me hear
what this [ __ ] is gonna say and as she
was super vulnerable like she was crying
and stuff and I'm like damn that's like
really hard for people to do cuz Mike
like she owed zero like she didn't have
to talk to me at all we could have just
what happened I would never cry in front
of you
I would never show weakness and smell it
do they smell fear
no and it's really dope it's really
refreshing because like now we're older
right so a lot of us tend to be a little
bit more jaded and we're like [ __ ] no we
already have our circle of friends why
do we need more you know so it's it was
really dope and refreshing to just have
someone there that's just like you know
what this is this is what I want I'm
gonna go after it I'm
show you my [ __ ] that's what I call
one oh yeah yeah I'm gonna show you my
[ __ ] and take it or leave it like I
don't know if I can do that like not at
this point
like I don't know if I can ever show
someone my [ __ ] that I don't want to
be my friend and then and be okay with
that cuz I'm like look it's a waste my
entire definitely takes a long time yeah
you know I think also like it's funny
that like JK news actually helps us bond
a lot too because you're supposed to be
unfiltered you're supposed to be candid
you're and then we go through so many
like controversial stories that you very
quickly see everyone's opinion yeah and
generally with the exhaustion of David
we're kind of all on a similar page you
know and then like if we are opposing
it's kind of like funny and then it's a
jokey place and we laugh at often so we
learn like if you're very crass like we
know not to take it seriously because
cameras go off and then we're like haha
but like I just also loved it when
working with you guys when the cameras
went off everyone was the [ __ ] same
yeah it's a huge day like there there
are no sense in LA and link Theo von
even called this out on the Joe Rogan
podcast he was like everyone in LA is so
fake what it was Theo von even hasn't
gone driven drew working like four times
I need a dedicated video just for us
well mentioned I want to hear this yeah
can we find it he actually says like
everyone in LA is so [ __ ] fake well
except JK news you ever work with them
he's like Oh ladies like yo guys I gotta
know the [ __ ] these [ __ ] drove Rogen
yeah but like you know for somebody
who's been there like just what two or
three times for them to just walk
candidly speaking think oh except for
those people there there's yes whole you
know like it's it but it is honestly I
have to also say it's hard to find girls
like y'all like it really is yeah it
really is so like you know if you're
still looking for your perfect girl
group like don't [ __ ] beat yourself
up you're gonna start to just slowly
create this close circle of friends and
if that's your jam that's [ __ ] fine
and if you don't have that close friend
of girls yet just learn to be
self-sufficient like emotionally like
financially like work why's that so hard
build yourself up yeah looking hard like
I like that we we're all very busy women
we have our own things going on we have
our own hustle and I like that fact that
even if I don't cuz I was gone when I
was like in Japan for four months even
when we're gone and we don't see each
other for a long time when we get back
we still know that we're friends like
it's not like oh she's never here for me
we understand
each other's lives and what we have to
do and not being there physically
doesn't mean that I'm not your friend a
lot of people don't get that either like
we're low maintenance friends it's what
I like to call it yeah hmm so we're
gonna take a quiz a quiz oh speaking of
banging have you ever been on different
kinds of furniture
have you ever banged on mid-century
modern furniture with the touch of
Scandinavian design yeah well if you
haven't you can definitely get some of
that furniture and we'll tell you how
yes so thank you so much to our next
sponsor article and this is not a joke
article actually has a really dope
selection of mid-century modern with a
touch of Scandinavian design furniture I
really do love it because especially if
you have like a small space because the
furniture is so like I mean I don't know
if you guys know what mid-century modern
looks like but it's a lot thinner
sleeker design it's not very bulky
looking so in small spaces it looks very
open very clean very beautiful I'm a big
fan I found them I want to say when they
first started like maybe five years ago
and they only had like four items or
something on there on their website but
there the quality of the furniture looks
so good that I'm like oh my god these
guys are gonna get really huge really
fast and here we are getting sponsored
by them so it's really dope because you
get to save up to 30% of traditional
costs or price because they don't have
so much overhead because they cut out
the middleman they cut out you know the
store and all the taxes up that they
have to pay on that and they go direct
to consumer meaning you guys you go
online find the piece of furniture that
you like you buy it you receive it it
gets delivered to your home and it's
easy 30-day return so you don't even
have to sweat it that's right ladies and
gentlemen it's time to grow up get your
furniture up off the floor get your
mattress off the floor put it on a bed
stop buying cheap furniture off of the
internet for $50 because you don't have
any money it's time to invest and you
can use code b-tch for $50 off of a
hundred that's right that's 50% off of
$100 that's beautiful upgrade a new
nightstand a plant
perhaps a pillow and a bed that's sturdy
enough for you to go nuts on like that
so just visit article dot-com slash b
TCH like po said
$50 off purchases of $100 or more
again that's article comm / b tch and
the discount will be automatically
applied at checkout that's article comm
/ b tch to get $50 off your first
purchase of $100 or more they gave me a
nice ass bed get yourself one too yeah
don't sleep on him but you should I
loved having those funds where you don't
talk for two months and then you start
talking and it's like you never left and
everything's perfect like you the
conversation like still flows you know I
feel so spoiled then so then just be
real just be open but like so these are
the things we're saying right but it's
like how the [ __ ] do you do that though
like when you've been so like I said
jaded and you've been so [ __ ] hurt
like like do you just go [ __ ] it do you
bust the bows and you just go I'm gonna
change some [ __ ] this is what I want and
then just Buster bows yeah weird it's
like voguing but bosey
oh I think that that's like an urban
dictionary phrase I think it means to
stick your finger up your butthole
posing yeah it's my name I didn't know
that at the time until somebody like
sent it to me and also I think in like
some Slavic language it means God Oh
actually means like oh my god or
goodness or something oh you know I
think back to what she was saying I
think how you would do it honestly it
was it's just a lot of trial and error
like don't give up and just put yourself
out there and meet friends you know and
sometimes you just find the right ones
and they just happen to come along and
then just be open to that and be open to
being that good friend like be the best
friend you can be to someone and if it
comes back to you then awesome then you
keep them forever if nothing you just
keep on what's the longest friend you
have my friend Anna who have known since
junior year of high school and I was her
bridesmaid I don't know yeah what's the
longest girlfriend you um my best friend
we went to alternative schools together
and we were just [ __ ] burnout pieces
of [ __ ] and like felt really rejected
we've been best friends for I think 15
years now oh damn she's such a boss ass
[ __ ] I love her what about you I still
have a friend her name is Amanda and we
knew each other since fifth grade Wow
yeah
I just saw her when I was in Houston I
went back to Texas when mom passed away
and I went to go see her when they post
it together Oh cute I'd like to say like
I haven't seen her in years cuz I've
been in LA but it's like the same [ __ ]
it's like the same girl that I've known
my whole life how do you guys maintain
those relationships though I actually
because I think that's where I struggle
a lot okay yeah no I get that too I like
Anna a special name with Orange County
and I still stayed here in LA I wouldn't
see her for like years at one point you
know or like we would just text each
other here and there but my friends like
I said they understand that I'm never I
don't I can't always be around but now
we're making a point more like hey you
know we're older we have it we have
money to do things you know so we
actually sit down and group chat like
it's we added a third edition right and
now we're like hey I really miss you
do you guys want to hang out like even
if it's just come on over watch some
anime and just play some monopolies in
that seven like you just have to make
that initiative and just text each other
and okay let's stop let's hang out but
other than that you don't have to always
be around each other and you have to
understand that - yeah how do you guys
maintain Geo who's your longest friend I
don't have the longest friend that's why
I'm like long as though um damn I would
say I do I really don't keep girlfriends
yeah you guys are like my girlfriend's
do you feel like you don't keep up with
them or do you feel like you push them
away at any problem yeah I feel like we
went like different I think I've met
them at a point where I was a different
person
hmm and then we kind of just grew apart
yeah and then for me it was more of like
like they were kind of it felt like it
was a fake friendship like we were just
being polite to be like this is what
friends are supposed to do mm-hmm I kind
of felt like that so then when I started
do that right now I just really I feel
really sad that you don't have
friendships longer than like five no I
don't cuz I think I changed so extremely
yeah so like in high school or I'll even
start I think it started in middle
school so in middle school I had a best
friend right we would do everything
together and then I go to high school
and she was just like I just changed I
became a STONER I was no longer like
trying to be a straight-a student and
[ __ ] like she didn't want to do to a lot
of things with you yeah she didn't want
to do trill that things with me at all
so I'm like oh she's kind of lame so
yeah because like my flakes say with my
friend Amanda like we know ages and
fifth grade we've gone through so many
different laces phases but like we've
stayed friends phases I think that means
like your compass was going like your
moral computation and your will going in
the same direction whereas Geo's like
hers and who was so weird completely
changed yeah so she was still doing this
straight-a student
route or whatever and I'm like Lua like
I have some freedom now like I want to
be part of the cool kids I would go in
this rod and we would try to stay
friends but I'm like I have zero in
common with you anymore you know and
then in high school I had the cool
friends and stuff but then they were out
having sex and they continued to get
high and I'm like oh damn like I'm gonna
graduate soon like I want to go to
college and stuff like we're not the
same anymore and even though I try to
stay connected with them like they'd get
pregnant and all these other things
would happen where I'm like [ __ ] I'm
like really dedicated and focused on
school now so it's like that kind of
just dropped off cuz I didn't have any
anything to talk about with them anymore
and then same thing with college I was
so focused I didn't even have
girlfriends in college so maybe now like
we are meant to be your longest friend
maybe because we're all in the same path
right now right oh sorry because Anna
and I told opposites she's like a church
singer very yeah she and I are very
opposite like a moral compass I guess
but we still have a lot of things in
common we still have like our like all
of our high school talks and everything
about to but we still have something in
a common ground as in our personalities
are the same even if our faith isn't the
same whatever and I think that's and
she's always wanted to be a better
person and I felt like she was almost a
better person to me and I wanted to be
that too and then we that's how we grew
together so I understand that and I
think that maybe this is the group
that's meant to last for a long time
baby you know like now we're not on
throw this away at all right I know I
don't know maybe this came from me dudes
uncover some [ __ ] man I actually feel
like I'm exactly the same way I have the
one long-standing friend and the funny
[ __ ] is we were talking on the sailor
day that we were like oh I'm gonna be in
town like I'll be in Virginia for
Christmas and we were like they don't
really need to hang out I was like yeah
no we don't really yeah we're not we're
not that type of person and then other
than her I don't have any long-standing
I had one girl that I met when I was 20
on Twitter we met on Twitter and we just
became really tight and then when I was
22 she was like hey I have a room
on Vegas $300 a month at a house and a
nice house in Vegas I was like let's
[ __ ] do this
she and I were so similar we had the
same like dark sense of humor we were
both anxious kind of depressed girls and
we supported each other but she was she
was a dancer she moved out to Vegas to
be a dancer at like 18 and I'm like she
she was a stripper like all the way up
until we just recently kind of stopped
being friends but as I became a little
more like successful and moved out here
and did this she was very bitter and
very angry with me and she would always
kind of have that support but the thing
is is I wasn't depressed anymore and she
was still absolutely depressed and so we
weren't eventually speaking the same
language anymore and it hurt me so much
it hurt me so much and after like two or
three times of us stopped talking coming
back stopping talking and coming back it
just like I couldn't do this anymore
like and it [ __ ] hurt but when people
are not on the same path is you anymore
sometimes they may try to pull you down
too you know you have to cut it off like
well I think I was probably pulling them
down I don't know I feel like with you
and how focused and successful that you
were maybe they were kind of envious and
he's cut you I don't know I mean we
still talk but I wouldn't consider them
type friends you know like I we didn't
hit them up like in the middle of the
night and be like hey I mean there's an
emergency like I still communicate with
them but it's not like a night I like I
see that's where she went wrong
because when I see someone doing better
than me like someone that has something
that I want like like Gio and you guys
I'm just like instead of being like that
[ __ ] it's like [ __ ] I really want to be
there with them you know like I want to
add up there with them so that like what
Bo says she's gonna write on our code
what did you say your codes hell
straight to the top like when I when I
saw your new house for the first time
like some people like suck like more
than what does she deserve is right it
was Casey I was kidding
I actually had a moment in your back
yard I was like [ __ ] this thing is huge
and I was like and I was like I'm going
to tell the universe right now like I
want to be like Bart Angie oh that's
horrible don't say that oh your eyes I
want to
a house like this one day and I'm going
to get that house it was inspirational
to me you know that you should be
inspired by your Verma not [ __ ] same
here I saw that post I even saw y'all's
old house you were selling and I was
like I need to do better you know what I
did I started like dead ass after I saw
like what you guys have built I started
diversifying my income I started I made
a goal I was like I want to make a
thousand dollars extra per month
and I was like I'm gonna try this this
and this she's selling feet photos yeah
I picked up some just other like
business operations in two weeks I made
that thousand dollars they go yeah like
dead ass and I mean like you should have
friends that inspire you whether you're
trying to or not did you know that geo
no thanks for that dough I want to cut
it cut no no a manager give me that copy
no I agree there's like I mean that's
just kind of how I am with people like
when I find someone that that I like
they are F when I find someone that has
things that I like or that I really
respect or admire then I'm like I need
that person well what do you admire
about me I admire how fearless you are
oh yeah you're super fearless but then
you're you're very loving and you're
very approachable and you're very humble
yeah you're just like a I just music
this positivity a little like happy
bubble all the time yeah I know a piece
of [ __ ] for you young fruity free free
like you're very free like you you're
not like yeah like not and you're
confident mm-hmm thank you I'm sassy as
a joke but thank you that made me feel
no I love it
yeah I can tell you what I like about
every single person that had that I have
in my life the people that I have in my
life I'm very specific to have them and
like it I have them for a reason and
it's not because I'm using anybody but
it's just cuz I'm so inspired by
everybody bows your neck wants to hear
I love your personality and I love how
nerdy you are and how we get along so
well
yeah they would like you and I like I
don't know hotel room out of all the
girls in the hotel or in the in all of
JK I was like holy [ __ ] I found my
counterpart right like because we have
like the the core for here right it was
great awesome you know like Tiffin and
Julie have their blue hair squad going
on and I'm like I want to find mine and
then I found you where the rbf's baby
hey oh dude you guys are I feel like all
we all have dynamics with each other I
feel like summer like still getting
built like I don't want my dynamic with
you as you go it's probably I'm like
it's like she's the tree you're the
climber picture you suckling are based
off of me running away from her breasts
suckling energy though know what I love
about poses or [ __ ] Energy's huge
yeah big present I love it you're a lot
of positive energy I saw I saw a
different side of bows though they both
kind of initially started to like at my
birthday she was like pull back a little
bit
hold on and her energy I noticed
affected me because I was like oh wait
where's Big Boss Bo yeah yeah and then
when she came down then I started like
smothering her because I was like are
you okay yeah like her you can like I
started projecting on her because when
her energy isn't huge it leaves your
sweet void like she like a different
side of her and I was like I actually
want to get to know her more I realized
okay I'm smothering this [ __ ] I'm gonna
step back but I wanna
she's not just always just big I felt it
yeah I wish I knew like what people
minima cuz I've been told before that I
had big energy like I met my boyfriend
on tender and the first time we got I
got into his car he was like you have a
really big presence and almost and I've
heard that a lot but I just I don't a
very simple way to put that is like for
you to understand it is if someone walks
up to you and goes how much money do you
make and you're just like what the [ __ ]
I don't know you but the fact that
they're confident to first walk up to
you they don't even know you that well
and then to ask you such a personal
question you're either gonna [ __ ]
hate that person you're gonna be like
okay well why do you want to know
you know and it's just like it takes a
big confident personality I think to say
[ __ ] like that she's exactly the same in
person and on in front of the camera
because like like look at her ad reads
dude like she's wild you know - ding
dong ding dong it's just as big energy
and then like then when it came to
innovate like this was my first in like
real interaction with Bose when we went
to Vegas together I was like I wonder
what she's like in person and she just
came in while I was sleeping boom when I
woke up she's like you ready to like
yeah she's like [ __ ] me too
she's like I'm not to walk around with
no shirt on k I'm like yeah let's do it
all your tits no shadow brawlin yeah
just really wait she's something wrong
I'm like the [ __ ] going on here I
don't make it titties out I didn't care
all right so what what our closing
thoughts here well how do we help Ari
I'm sorry good no no no go ahead
Oh take your time you don't need like
that big group of friends now we found
each other late and it's awesome yeah
you just got a vibe it out and feel
people out and find your group and it
doesn't matter how long it takes [ __ ] I
might find my super bestest friend in an
old people home when I'm dying right
wheelchairs and I'll turn off for air it
just takes it's pinching the cord yeah
you know like don't don't freak out
about it now like a lot of people who
commented on the in our videos it's like
I notice they were a little bit younger
like it'll take some time because
everyone's still trying to learn
themselves before they can put
themselves in someone else's life yeah
what do I guess I would say like don't
you know your experiences helped build
you and it also helps kind of strengthen
that receptor that I talked about
because like we don't just have that
naturally it's like through our
experiences of who [ __ ] worked out
and who didn't but as you start to get a
little older I would say my receptor was
strong at like 18 and that's why I ain't
[ __ ] with nobody but when you meet a
[ __ ] that it's going be me baby baby
baby
like good [ __ ] like extend your hand
don't be afraid of rejection and try to
build that relationship and like if it
works out like the first couple of times
you guys chill just like feel it out you
know like yeah that's time I think for
me it's
very helpful to realize that with women
like we're all very sensitive we're all
very in our own heads we're all like
thinking about ourselves how like what
we are showing the world like and so
we're all in our own head so don't take
things that women do necessarily to
heart right away or at least like give
yourself a chance to like talk to
someone like if things don't go right
the first time you hang out try again
like or like try to be more honest like
hey I want to hang out with you I think
you're kind of cool but like I don't
know I get this weird thing like are you
like you know you'd be able to talk to
women I think like because I've probably
missed so many relationships because I
like it didn't sit down and say like did
you really mean that or liked am I
taking it really yeah having a
conversation and communication like you
would with a partner I think is really
it's hard you ask questions you have to
like talk to women like to understand
them because they're probably just in
their own head like or they just broke
up with her boyfriend so they're like
lashing out at other people and like if
you can actually break down your
emotions with another woman like I feel
like you'll be closer away faster I
think - what you're saying is like if a
girl came up to me and was like hey Bo's
did you really mean that when you said
did you mean it this way because I felt
like it was that I would immediately
break that and be like this a real [ __ ]
you know like I'm not weird if you
communicate with people it's not it
feels hard but you fighting yourself you
know like not the not the external
forces people like to be communicated
with yeah yeah and the final final fine
I'll keep it really really brief I think
it's really important to have your
circle of girlfriends because it's it's
I mean as you guys have seen from this
podcast like you guys can can can
connect with other females and be like
oh [ __ ] I'm not the only one that's
going through this and I can relate to
that girl and and it's stoked to have
like the support system of like I'm not
alone like this is tight and like people
have their best interests in me and it's
someone that looks like me and goes
through the same [ __ ] that I go through
so yeah it's really important if you
can't find it now
definitely search for it try to stay
vulnerable be tight and yeah just keep
it positive okay that's it I'm done
thank you guys for listening I watching
you you guys next week all right but
before we go ladies and gentlemen I want
to say another thank you to our sponsors
care of remember that's 25% off your
first care of order go to CARICOM and
enter b tch again that's 25% off your
first care of or
go to take care of oh my bad so I did
say wrong let's take care of take care
of dot-com I'm gonna say that again it's
take care of calm and entrecôte b tch
also huge thank you to function of
beauty so you guys are gonna get 20% off
your first order to redeem it head over
to function of beauty calm slash b tch
and take the hair quiz again that's
function of beauty combi TCH for 20% off
ladder I should definitely not least
it's article so it's $50 off your first
purchase of 100 hours or more so go to
article calm slash b tch again if you're
a little bit to know its article dot-com
slash b tch for $50 off your first
purchase of $100 or a Miller